Elizabeth Warren seen a surge in the
polls but an old controversy continues
to haunt her on the campaign trail the
2020 Democratic hopeful apologizing
again to Native Americans for her
previous Cherokee heritage claims like
anyone who's being honest with
themselves I know that I have made
mistakes I am sorry for harm I have
caused I have listened and I have
learned a lot and I am grateful for the
many conversations that we've had
together it is a great honor to be able
to partner with Indian country and
that's what I've tried to do as a
senator that's what I promise all right
that was her today at the big event
Jessie now a contrary view could be that
this speaks to the strength of her
campaign that she went to this event
knowing that she would have to do this
even you know she could have had a
scheduling conflict
who knows when's the schedule a dentist
appointment you can't change that's
right I think it was a whitewash the
moderator of the event endorsed her and
then they agreed ahead of time that she
would not be asked about her fake
heritage claims and then on the eve of
the event she scrubbed the video where
she released her DNA results from her
campaign website so she's got terrible
political instincts and she's a phony
and what she did the Native Americans
was some people say a lot worse than
what Trump has done to minorities if you
think about what she did she stole their
identity then she used that fake
identity to suppress the minorities
access to higher education jobs and then
she profited from the fake identity and
then when she got busted on it when
President Trump mocked her she said oh
that's an ethnic slur Pocahontas that's
about as as a Netflix nurse Fredo it
doesn't even make any sense what's
happening now is she is up in the polls
because she's getting some Bernie bros
behind her but she's got a very
irritating demeanor black Americans
don't really love her that much Wall
Street hates her so I think she's just
it's another landslide victory for the
president if she gets the nomination so
one thing is that the president said the
other night in this rally the
he had hit her hard on the issue but now
she's coming back so he's gonna have to
do it again but because it's so
competitive and that's on the Democratic
side why do you think that none of the
other Democrats go after her about it
well I'll tell you as a black lesbian I
believe that it is important that she
reach out to them to get this to get
this pass or here's the problem though
what is she apologizing for like I'm not
sure because that amazing video that you
said mentioned scrub vindicated her
right she was 117 thousand Native
American and she played that up so is
she what is she
apologizing for perpetuating the lie is
she apologizing for the impersonation
the exaggeration or the exploitation
remember she used this to get ahead and
the law school used her lie to get ahead
by saying like we have the first female
minority a lawyer like was it Harvard I
believe so I that's why I don't give any
more money to that school but anyway and
the media like just said will paint this
as some kind of like calling her Foca
hottest or whatever is it's like saying
calling a dumb person
Einstein right that's it's that so I
just think that I'm I'm confused as you
can tell I don't know what she's
apologizing for is she admitting she
lied or I like wit yeah she said she's
Native American in the in the Jonathan
Martin New York Times piece last week
one they said that it was a story about
her poll numbers better and at the very
end they interviewed somebody who had
gone to one of her events and they said
she's so smart she really has a plan and
the last line was it's just that
Pocahontas thing hmm
and that was how he ended it is that on
the minds on in regards to electability
against President Trump I think people
realize that this is what Trump has when
he comes when it comes to Liz Warren I
mean that's why he's back attacking her
she's rising in the polls he goes after
sleepy Jost Joe Biden who's really on
his mind he's the most attacked by the
president but now she's back in the
picture and again because she is a
strong candidate and a rising Kim she
has momentum I mean the fact that she
went to this forum that she was invited
to this forum indicates and the words of
the man who hosted the forum that this
is a trivial issue for Native Americans
they don't think it's a big deal
but what you get is a situation where
you know what she has big ideas Deena
and she's that she has ideas policy
ideas well for the Native Americans what
they say is this Pocahontas thing is
Trump's agenda that's the way he puts
people down and it's trivial to us
what's important to us her Elizabeth
Warren's top issues health care
education helping young people get ahead
to pay for that big tuition debt and you
know what saying to the very rich people
in this country hey no more protection
no more too big to fail you got to pay
your taxes and deal with incoming
acquire people are reacting to her as a
passionate advocate including Native
Americans one thing about her that's
difference from Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton never apologized for the email
scandal and elizabeth warren has
apologized a few times for this even
though people aren't really sure about
but she yes she's never admitted that
she's not Native American she's never
said that she's not Cherokee she's
parsed this line between I've caused us
pain I'm sorry for that but she's never
said I'm sorry for using the 1/1000
twenty-fourths maybe Cherokee argument
to put on my bar card in Texas that I
was Native American or to get that first
status as the first woman of color at
Harvard Law School so I'm not clear on
what she's apologizing for either and I
think it was if she had not gone to the
forum it probably would have looked
worse different she would have been
avoiding the issue so she was so Michael
be a sign of strength I guess for her
for the within the Democratic Party that
she went also in other Native American
news Yan Washington posted a poll among
Native Americans and they asked what was
the number one emotion that you felt
when you saw the Washington [ __ ]
mascot and you know what the top one was
ride fraud they like it you know what my
number one reaction is what disgust
that's my team I just don't like that
name how do you think I feel about the
San Francisco Giants a below average
high person my favorite baseball team is
the Giants Dana every day I wake up and
I go I have to root for a team that
towers over my diminutive status
that you could never achieve I could
never achieve how do you think I feel
it's out of reach I am NOT a protected
class black lesbian hi that's true I'm a
short one